die maya hochkultur war im ersten
jahrtausend nach christus wohl weiter
entwickelt als die meisten anderen
zivilisationen dieser zeit doch
plötzlich verschwand sie scheinbar bis
heute liegen noch immer viele aspekte
dieser mysteriösen kultur im dunkeln wie
beispielsweise eben auch die ursachen
für ihren untergang und das rätsel ist
immer noch nicht gelöst warum genau
setzte ab dem achten jahrhundert nach
christus ein derart rasanten niedergang
ein
jetzt hat ein forschungsteam aus
cambridge vielleicht die antwort darauf
gefunden alle wichtigen infos jetzt bei
pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen ihr untergang kam plötzlich
und bis heute ist das rätsel um das ende
der maya hochkultur nicht gelüftet und
das obwohl viele schriftzeichen
entschlüsselt werden konnten fest steht
der dschungel hat am ende die
verlassenen städte in windeseile
überwuchert bisher wurden drei faktoren
und auch deren kombination als ursache
in erwägung gezogen krieg raubbau und
dürre
schon frühere untersuchungen wiesen auf
eine außergewöhnliche dürreperiode zu
dieser zeit hin boden ablagerungen
hätten gezeigt dass es in dem meyer
gebiet um 900 nach christus eine
trockenheit gegeben haben soll um diese
theorie näher zu kommen hat jetzt ein
britisches forschungsteam ablagerung aus
einem see in der nähe der stadt medina
untersucht konkret ging es um eine
abgeschlossene lagune auf der süd
mexikanischen halbinsel yucatan
hier konnten sich die meier wohl ein
wenig länger halten als im südlichen
tiefland das von urwald durchzogen ist
das forschungsteam analysiert in
verschiedene ablagerungen und konnte so
rückschlüsse auf die vorherrschenden
umweltbedingungen ziehen
die erklärung dafür bei extremer
trockenheit verdunsten leichte partikel
und die schweren bleiben zurück dabei
können dann gibt's kristalle entstehen
in denen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler tatsächlich ein
geschlossenes uraltes wasser fanden
dieses untersuchten sie auf verschiedene
isotope von wasser und sauerstoff denn
bei trockenheit verdunsten
logischerweise zunächst die leichteren
isotope höhere anteile von schweren
isotopen dagegen lassen auf eine
dürrephase rückschließen um zu
vergleichen bediente sich das
forschungsteam an ablagerungen aus der
jahren 1994 bis 2010 denn in diesem
zeitraum waren niederschläge und
temperatur genau ermittelt worden
die analyse der damit aufgestellten
thema modelle zeigte ein überraschendes
ergebnis der aktuellen analyse zufolge
kann man davon ausgehen dass die
jährliche niederschlagsmenge damals
teilweise um achtung bis zu 70 prozent
unter den heutigen werten gelegen haben
muss dazu schreiben sie in ihrer studie
wir fanden hohe wahrscheinlichkeit für
einen trockenheit insbesondere am anfang
etwa 750 bis 850 nach christus und am
ende etwa 950.000 50 nach christus der
späten klassischen phase
diese daten sollen jetzt genutzt werden
um konkret herauszufinden wie dadurch
die damalige landwirtschaft der maya
kultur in mitleidenschaft gezogen wurde
selbst wenn zudem weiterer faktoren wie
beispielsweise krieg beim kollaps der
hochkultur eine rolle gespielt haben
sollten zeigt dieses ergebnis deutlich
welche fatalen folgen klimatische
veränderungen für das leben auf der erde
haben können und tatsächlich könnte es
auch ein indiz dafür sein wie unsere
aktuelle zivilisation untergehen könnte
durch den menschengemachten klimawandel
er ist für uns tatsächlich
existenzbedrohend wenn ihr kein video
verpassen wollt auch extra videos und
livestreams nicht dann werdet mitglied
hier auf dem kanal und nehmt auch noch
ein paar privilegien mit außerdem
unterstützen sie uns mit einem kleinen
betrag einfach auf mitglied werden die
klicken direkt hier unter dem video und
vielen vielen vielen dank an alle die
schon mitglied geworden sind das macht
uns etwas unabhängiger von schwankenden
werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube ja dann
das kennt er schon werden noch nicht
drauf gekriegt hat auf jeden fall hier
uns auf whatsapp folgen da werdet ihr
nämlich immer aktuell informiert wenn
ein neues video online geht auf jeden
fall auch unseren schwesterkanal
abonnieren klicks um social media das
geht hier und natürlich nicht die glocke
vergessen
ich mach's nochmal genau die und hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken die mythen der sumerer
mysteriös und rätselhaft bis dann bleibt
dran